welcome to your mom's house
by the way I was watching a little bit
with my sister was here with her fiance
and we were started to watch pee-wee's
big holiday right right that's a new
movie you know what would amaze me
they go how old is peewee and I said
he's got to be late 40s I was assuming
you know and anyways I looked it up
do you know how old he is 50 63 pee-wee
Herman's 63 63 years old
Wow that would make sense because what
does when you really think about yeah
but it's still wow he looks great dude
pee-wee Herman is a special effect
really to make him look younger blue
brown says Oh in that villain yeah oh
that's a known thing oh so you read an
article that says and they made him look
younger
I guess the character has to be that
young the whole thing is that the
character is yeah like eternal youth but
yeah but we're talking about a guy who's
not far from 70 that's right it looks
great even being you know that whole
thing it was so sad that he lost his
career over jerking it in a porno
theater who hasn't done that right I
mean if I had half his career I'd be
fucking in the dumps right many times
over I've jerked off and fucking phone
booths hospitals right Yeah right
funerals absolutely my dad's funeral
your dad's dude yeah but I mean look of
all places to jerk off in public that's
kind of where you're supposed to jacket
is at the movie theater that plays dirty
movies and he got really reinforced
because I had just read about him and
apparently you know there was like a
sting operation going on there and they
had arrested some people in the theater
and he was actually walking out
someone spotted him and it's almost like
they were like oh that's and he goes I'm
famous and then get him and then he
offered the police department to do a
show for free for like kids in the area
to make this door go away
yeah and then his lawyers also
approached the DA with that with like
can he do it and they were like oh no of
course not
that's terrible oh when you think about
the transgressions of other famous
people like George Michael wasn't he
jerking in a bath no Joel no blowjob
blowjob and didn't ruin his career
yeah well that's the thing that sucked
for peewee is that the children oh well
I mean can't we teach our kids about
masturbating is that not part of the
curriculum anymore I mean your dad
probably showed you how to masturbate
very early it's one thing that he was
not those two didn't talk about that huh
not even a tiny tiny bit that's terrible
yeah no no I don't think my parents
slightest I can remember a couple
masturbation things as a kid one time I
had masturbated and I just wanted to
kind of feel like it was somewhat you
know okay I knew what I was doing but
you know I wasn't product n so I went to
my dad and I go um I was taking a shower
I was washing you know between my legs
and then this stuff came out and he goes
don't wash along next time and then
walked away I was like huh I guess I
should do that
yeah did you feel guilty of course yeah
so weird
another time I remember I approached him
and I was like um do you ever masturbate
I just straight up asked him and he goes
one time when I was 16 I was like that's
it and he was like yeah but what would
be better like I was thinking about it
would you want your dad to talk to you
about nothing
or something I want you to watch me do
something not like that but I think I
think the approach that I would have
preferred would be like hey just so you
know I mean it would've been weird right
even like yeah masturbating I don't hear
about like just so you know you know you
do it in private in your room or in the
bathroom it's normal to do it not ten
times a day but you're gonna you know
it's gonna have like just let you know
that you're in the realm of normal
behavior
right yeah someone need to tell you that
like I felt like I was a total dude
that's interesting because even like my
mother bought me a book called what's
happening to my body yeah and it was so
dumb and I you know I told you about
armpit hair and periods yeah but I don't
even think there was a section about
masturbate it totally should be their
shit that should have been like chapter
one hey this is what you should be doing
it's normal
sometimes when you do this it makes you
pussy feel good yeah like that right are
you gonna talk to our son about this for
sure like at what age six six no no no
but when he's a little bit I don't know
probably getting into puberty yeah I
live in a man it was the rules okay I'm
gonna stroke your hair I'm gonna do yeah
do it in the bathroom try to get it down
the drain if you do in your bedroom no
my ear shut the door nobody wants to
hear about it nobody wants to hear about
it and don't make mom clean your laundry
with your crusty socks and stuff I bet
you did that right oh yeah you're such a
dope oh shoot it into my boxers oh my
god I'm gonna throw crust up and then I
would throw them under the bed so then
like six to twelve pairs of rusty boxers
and I just throw them in the laundry
chute ah
and your mother did it yeah she never
said anything any like course not
Chinese were kind of you know I used to
do that I'll be embarrassed by them so I
would soak there was a sink next to our
laundry machine I don't know whatever
it's just a laundry sink and I would
throw all my boxers in there and wet
them so they would they would get right
that's humane yeah they would soak cuz
you don't really have a sense of shame
like I asked you to stop by the
drugstore to make some sexual purchases
for us
and you left the bag of rubbers just no
not even that you just took it out of
the box put it right on the credenza
right in the hallway whoever comes over
can just see our box of rubbers thank
you yeah thank you have any sense of
shame number the other one the the cock
rings yeah that was fun in our
housekeeper put them in a plastic bag
for you but I told you she didn't know
what she does not know that's why she
put them in a sanitary ziploc bag next
to your bed
she didn't say shit no that's the best
part about her is that she's these keep
your cock hard mister give your cock our
eco kids soft something if you lose
weight maybe your cock it harder thank
you for that I notice you you're very
fast and in fact the body fat will
deterioration but the cock ring made you
come hard to see pussy is dry lubricant
I'm sorry what Nancy Wow Nancy Jesus
Christ you're like half hard cocking so
you're hurt how do you know because we
fuckin I think go back that we agree she
said something she's found so much of
our nasty shit I mean that's a house
that's the bond that is the rust they
know all your shit oh you're so good
tomorrow which is gonna be like in your
boxers
these are shark boxers in the trash can
oh I know cuz I'm like what did you do
with your shitty boxers I threw him in
the trash well then Nancy's gonna get
those too
you see your diet makes you shit
yes yeah stop being so fatty one shot
and you'll get hurt again